let's go next to our caller from the
seven one six area code who's calling
today from seven one six hey who's this
Xavier what's up alright so I can't
support Joe Biden I'm sorry but his
record on segregation crime the crime
bill and his allegations with Tara Reid
I can't support bite him but I will say
this I do would you agree that it is the
most important thing that we do is to
flip this on it because if you think
about it if Donald Trump gets reelected
and you have a Republican Senate that's
gonna be a disaster you're gonna get
more terrible policies pass if you have
a Joe Biden presidency but you have a
Republican Senate I fear that that's
going to enable bite into a route to
work with Republicans more to do that to
do like horrible things maybe like cut
Social Security Medicaid because he said
he is willing to put that on the table
right but I do think if you so let me
let me let's back up so okay hold on so
in the 90s Joe Biden said he would not
rule and so I don't even care about that
like the this is old stuff but I think
it's important for people to understand
when you say Joe Biden is considering
cutting Social Security and Medicare Joe
Biden during it was either an
interviewer or debate in the 90s said he
wouldn't a priori take off the table
cuts to Social Security and Medicare Joe
Biden didn't propose any such cuts and
that was almost 30 years ago and he's
not talking about that now so like we
can we can think whatever we think about
Joe Biden but you understand that I
can't I can't let you come in and say
Joe Biden is thinking about cutting
Social Security and Medicare when what
happened was in the 90s he said he
wouldn't a priori take it off the table
but he's not advocated for it and he
certainly isn't running on that now you
know that right we are not running on
that now but you see my eMpAtHy's right
in the 90s when he was asked in a
situation he
said I wouldn't blindly take it off the
table now I disagree with that position
I I would say we're not cutting it he
didn't say it in the 90s but that has
nothing to do with what he's running on
now I don't want people to hear that and
think the wrong thing so here's my
perspective I don't think there's any
sense in me saying it's more important
that Biden beat Trump or it's more
important that Democrats take the Senate
these are separate elections and they
will very much go together so for
example in a state like Montana Biden is
he's losing but he's polling way better
than Democrats have done in the past and
the incumbent Republican senator in
Montana is losing right now to Steve
Bullock so there's not really this one
or the other thing and they're going to
be decided separately although they've
seemed to move in parallel if Biden does
really well it's more likely that a
bunch of Republican senators would lose
so I don't think it's the right approach
to say it's more important to take the
Senate it's actually these things are
linked and you can vote you get a vote
for the Senate and you get a vote for
president and we can do both okay all
right Xavier thank you very much
appreciate the phone call